As I said before, there are two different dimensions of consciousness. You have
wakefulness and awareness. So we can be awake, which is exactly what it
implies. How awake are we, or are we asleep? And then we can be aware, or
alert. This means to what extent are we aware? Of both our external
surroundings and our internal world, meaning how we feel emotionally. Like are
we afraid, excited, or are we aware that we're in physical pain? Such as having
a headache or perhaps a pulled muscle? And this is also being aware of our
cognitions, so what it is that we're thinking. Here, let's look at this on a
diagram. We have awareness and wakefulness. We can have minimal consciousness
meaning we're not aware or awake, which would be here. This would be an example
of a coma. Or we could be fully aware and awake, we'd be up here. So this would
be something like practicing the piano maybe. How about in the middle of the
continuum, so moderate consciousness? Think about this. Have you ever been
asked a question by a friend, something like, what is the name of that
restaurant we went to for Homer's birthday last month? You know that you know
the answer to that question, but you just can't bring it to the level of
consciousness that allows you to respond appropriately. Most of us have had
experiences such as this. Whether it's an acquaintance's name that we should
know, we just can't remember it, the name of a restaurant, or even a movie that
we've seen. All of these are examples of something called the tip of the tongue
phenomenon.